Canada has always had a reputation as
being the well-behaved British colony
whilst its southern neighbor rebelled
and broke free the British Northern
Territory stayed loyal and wanted
nothing to do with it yet Canada like so
many other territories of the British
Empire did have its own armed revolution
which will be a surprise to many so
Canada didn't really exist at this point
and was actually a series of British
colonies the two important ones were
Upper Canada capital Toronto and to its
north Lower Canada focused on Montreal
and being host to a majority
french-speaking population throughout
the early nineteenth century the people
of these two canada's had wished for
wide sweeping reforms to the colonies
and the answer in case you were
wondering was no this was because both
of the Canada's were run by closed-off
anti-democratic oligarchy collectives in
Lower Canada it was the Chateau clique
made up of mostly Englishmen who wanted
the French speakers there to integrate
to an English way of life which in case
you're wondering did not endear them to
the population in Upper Canada it was
the family compact in charge and it was
also hostile to democracy these groups
obviously had their critics in Upper
Canada the primary critic was William
Lyon Mackenzie who led the reform
movement and in Lower Canada it was
louise joseph papp anew the leader of a
group called the Patriots in 1832 after
some protesters in Montreal were shot by
Crown soldiers Papineau sent a list of
demands to the British government in
order to reform the colony Britain and
the lower Canadian leaders decided that
they weren't going to launch any reforms
and it actually everything was perfect
already and over the next five years
tensions continued to rise in the
deadlock continued in November 1837
things started to turn a bit radical and
the lower Canadian government attempted
to arrest Pappa knew he fled south to
the United States and his supporters
began to violently resist government
attempts to round people up the
government wasn't able to suppress this
quickly and it soon turned into a
full-scale revolt against British rule
in Upper Canada seeing their neighbors
revolt they were in full swing Mackenzie
and his followers followed suit and
began their own uprising they did well
at first because the troops there had
been moved out of the province but the
revolutionaries had one major issue
they weren't professional soldiers this
didn't stop Mackenzie from declaring the
creation of the Republic of Canada which
then promptly collapsed that the
revolutionaries were defeated by local
militiamen you would assume that that
was it them for the Canadian revolution
but fun fact
no the rebellion had garnered a great
deal of interest in the United States
and many there were sympathetic to the
Canadians plight some Americans formed
groups which welcome Mackenzie and Pappa
knew and sought to help them in making
Canada Republic this eventually led to a
group of American volunteers could the
hunter brothers crossing the border in
invading Canada and it wasn't long
before British troops killed Americans
which inflamed tensions
now obviously armed American citizens
invading Canada was a cause for concern
in both London and Washington who didn't
want war in the end both sides came to
an agreement to suppress Americans
crossing the border and in Canada itself
the lower Canadian rebellion had been
completely crushed by the end of 1838 so
what did this mean for Canada and the
rebels or Britain wanted to prevent a
rebellion from happening again and so it
tasked all durham to make a list of
recommendations for reform the first and
the only one that was initially followed
was the unification of the Canada's into
just one Canada and as for the leaders
of the rebellion they remained in exile
in the USA eventually though they were
pardoned and returned to Canada and so
the Canadian Revolution was over and
whilst it didn't create an independent
Canadian Republic it did to a certain
extent create Canada I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with the special thanks to my patreon
supporters who you can see on screen
here and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologist
party-boy Co Danny Maloney Colin
Castleman Rob Waterhouse are in the
white Michael Reynolds H way an emperor
Chris wicker Gustav Swan Gareth Turner
spinning three plates David Silverman
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski
Christian check' Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Ike